NAVI RADJOU: Good
morning, everyone.
It's a great pleasure
for me to be here
with you to talk about frugal
innovation, which is also
the topic of my new book that
just got published by Economist
a few weeks ago.
So I thought it's
better to begin
with some kind of background
on what is this concept called
frugal innovation and trace
its origins a little bit, which
in a way connects to my own
professional development.
I've been a
management consultant
to companies in the US and
Europe for about 15 years,
and about 10 years
ago, we began to hear
some interesting comments from
senior executives in companies
that we consulted.
They began to note a couple
of things about the innovation
model.
The first one is that
innovation is becoming
more and more expensive.
As you may know, it
costs a lot of R&D money
to do innovation to the point
where last year alone, PwC
estimates that large
companies in the world
spent about $647 billion in
R&D. So the first thing is
it costs more money to do
R&D. That's the first thing.
The second issue is that R&D
is also becoming more resource
intensive.
If you look at areas like
apparel industry, electronics,
it takes a lot of natural
resources to make these items.
For example, it's nice to have
the latest fashionable jeans,
but it cost about
10,000 liters of water
to produce one pair of jeans.
Or you take Kingfisher,
which is Europe's largest
home improvement retailer.
They consume the food which is
the equivalent of a mini forest
the size of
Switzerland every year.
So clearly, natural resources
are required as well
to come up with the latest
and fanciest products as well,
and we know that
natural resources
are dwindling as well.
The third factor is that
most companies are telling us
that actually,
they're having trouble
not just inventing ideas, but
actually commercializing them.
And one of the reasons is
because these companies
are stuck in very rigid
processes that prevent them
from innovating
very, very quickly.
And this is a nice quote
from Beth Comstock,
the CMO of General
Electric, who says
"We're not innovating
fast enough,"
and "We need to
systematize change."
So there's a need
for speed as well,
which is increasing
in large companies.
And then the next
important phenomenon
that we don't talk about is that
latest and fanciest innovation
is great, but the real
question is, is it
really what we call
trickle down so that it
benefits the entire society?
Not really sure.
Take financial
services sector that
invests in amazing
technologies every year
in terms of mobile
tools, et cetera,
but the fact is that 68 million
Americans, just about one fifth
of the US population
today, is under-banked.
They don't have access
to the full gamut
of financial services we take
for granted like debit card,
credit card, or
a saving account.
So clearly, there is some
problem with innovation
because on one
hand, it's becoming
costlier, more
resource intensive,
and yet it's not
benefiting everyone.
So we told ourselves,
we need to look
for a new model of innovation
somewhere in the world that
will be less costly, more
eco-friendly, more flexible,
and then more inclusive.
So we told ourselves,
where can we
look and find this new model?
Well, we said, let's go to these
emerging markets like India,
China, Africa, and
Brazil because they're
growing very quickly.
As you can see, over
the last 10 years,
they're outpacing
the Western world
in terms of economic growth.
So when we went to
the emerging markets
and we began to look at how
innovators, entrepreneurs
actually innovate, we
discovered that they
have a very unique mindset.
Let me give you one example
of such an entrepreneur.
Mansukhbhai Prajapati
is a porter by training
who actually invented the
world's greenest fridge.
It's called MittiCool.
It consumes no electricity,
it is made entirely of clay,
and can consume food and
vegetables for about five days.
And this is a boon for
a country like India,
where 700 million people
live off direct city grid.
So the first thing we noticed
among these entrepreneurs
in emerging markets is that
they had this amazing ability
to turn constraints
into an opportunity,
in particular
resource constraints.
Let's look at another example of
an innovation that illustrates
this kind of resilient mindset.
This is in Peru, a country
that has a 95% humidity rate
and only receives one inch
of rainfall every year.
A local engineering college
invented this giant advertising
billboard that absorbs
humidity in the air,
condenses it, purifies it,
and then generates over
90 liters of drinkable
water every day.
So they take what is
abundant, humidity,
to address what is scarce,
which is lack of water.
And now what we begin
to see is that you
have amazing innovators
in emerging markets who
are using this kind
of frugal ingenuity
to begin to deliver services
on a larger scale in areas
like health care, education,
energy, for example,
and finance in emerging markets.
So this is Dr. Devi Shetty.
He's a cardiologist who was
the personal surgeon of Mother
Teresa and today operates
a giant health city
in southern India where
he can perform a heart
surgery for $3,000, whereas in
the US, it costs about $50,000.
And it doesn't do
that as a charity.
That means everybody pays.
Even the poorest people
can avail the service,
except they pay using
a micro payment model.
So this is not philanthropy.
This is a for-profit model
that is also inclusive.
And then the biggest
continent in the world
that is going to teach
us a lot about this kind
of frugal innovation is Africa.
It's a country where we have
two interesting phenomena,
and I think many of you I
heard are mobile experts,
so you like statistics.
80% of Africa is under banked.
They don't have bank accounts.
They don't have
access to electricity.
They don't have access to
many services or bank account,
of course, but 80% of
Africans have a mobile phone.
So what you begin to see is that
mobile connectivity is becoming
the foundation for delivering
all kinds of services
that we have in the
West, whether it's
banking services, energy,
education, health care,
you name it.
So this is M-Pesa-- you might
have heard about it-- in Kenya,
which is a mobile
service that enables half
the population to send, receive
money using their mobile phone
without having a bank account.
50% of the country's GDP is
transacted with the service.
So what happens is that
like a mobile iPhone--
I'm sorry, Android, whatever you
want to use, again, a platform.
Once you have a platform
like Android, iPhone,
then you can start plugging
apps on top of that.
So now what's happening is
that this telephony platform
is enabling Kenyans
and the rest of Africa
to avail other
kinds of services,
not just products that we take
for granted, but basic services
like solar energy.
Now they can buy this
kit for a few dollars.
It's called M-KOPA.
It's a home solar system, and
this allows them essentially
to get solar energy on
a pay as you go basis.
So they just make a
micro payment daily,
and as long as they
make a micro payment,
they can have access
to the system.
And you might have
heard yesterday
that in Tanzania, the
government decided
to leapfrog from
candlelight, which
is the main source of
energy, to solar light
by installing this
kind of solution
into one million houses in 2017.
So what Africa is
teaching us is they're
going to leapfrog directly
from traditional banking
to mobile banking, from
candlelight to solar light,
using, among other things,
mobile connectivity.
So we wrote our first
book on this concept
of frugal innovation
or frugal science
because we noticed that even
in the scientific world,
this kind of frugality
can be useful.
As a case in point, this is
a spatial mission launched
by NASA called Maven for Mars,
and this satellite actually
entered Mars's orbit on the
22nd of September last year.
Two days later, India's
own space mission
was completed when Mangalyaan,
their own satellite,
entered Mars's orbit.
The difference is
that they carried out
this project 10 times
cheaper than NASA
and three times faster
by essentially doing
a lot more software
simulation, for example,
instead of making
physical prototypes
and things like that.
So this is called
frugal science.
It's basically a
cost effective way
of conducting scientific
experiments and space
exploration as well.
So we actually
wrote a book on it
about two years ago called
"Jugaad Innovation."
"Jugaad" is a Hindi word.
It means an
improvised fix, a kind
of MacGyver spirit of innovating
with limited resources.
And then after that, we began
to notice that actually,
wait a second, this kind
of frugal innovation
becomes more and more relevant
in the Western world as well.
Why is that?
Because first of all, since
the economic recession
began in 2008, we begin to
see more frugal behavior
among consumers in
the US and Europe.
Today, the top 10% richest
Americans account for about 60%
consumer spending in America.
Wages are stagnating, and
that means that middle class
Americans and
Europeans are looking
for more value with the limited
money they're willing to spend.
So as a result, we begin to see
some what we call permanently
value conscious behavior,
like people seeking discounts
more and more, or people looking
for private labels instead
of brands.
And then more importantly,
there's a frugal lifestyle
that people are
choosing by saying
I want to live with
less, not because I'm
constrained to do it, because
I want to do that way.
So this is the first thing is
that consumers are becoming
more value conscious, but
the real more important trend
is that consumers are becoming
values conscious as well.
This is a global
study done by Nielsen
that shows that 55%
of consumers are
willing to pay even extra money
for brands from companies that
are socially and
environmentally responsible,
and two thirds of
people around the world
want to work for
companies that actually
are socially and environmentally
responsible as well.
So it means that
they're not just
seeking more value
for money, but they're
looking for more values
as well from brands.
So as a result, we
might say, well,
what does it mean
for big companies?
Well, we'll come to that in a
moment, but what is exciting
is that this is leading
actually consumers to turn
to what we call prosumers.
It's basically a play on words
between producer and consumer.
That means that they're
not passive users
of goods and services.
They become active producers
of goods and services or value
creators themselves.
And this is actually enabled
by sharing goods and services
among consumers themselves,
which is the sharing economy,
and sometimes consumers making
their own products, which
is the maker movement
we'll talk about as well.
And overall, these are becoming
the two pillars of what
I call the frugal economy.
A frugal economy
is, in a nutshell,
an economy where supply
can meet demand in a cost
effective, environmentally
friendly way.
So this is actually
enabled, as I said,
by the sharing economy, which
is the first pillar of this.
And this is something, as
you know, it's about Airbnb,
it's about car sharing, and
this is actually exploding.
As a matter of fact, this
is the most recent study
that has been published by PwC
that shows that the sharing
economy on the B2C side is
going to explode from about $13
or $15 billion today to
$335 billion dollars,
20 times higher,
in about 10 years.
Now, this is just the tip
of the iceberg, folks.
This is the B2C side
of sharing, and we'll
talk about later what
happens if you transpose
this model of sharing goods
and services and assets
to the corporate
world in the B2B side,
and that's where it's going to
get even bigger than this one.
So that's the first
trend, the fact
that the sharing
economy is taking off,
and it's taking off very,
very quickly because of one
important factor, is that
this is an economy which
doesn't require fixed assets.
Take an example in the
hospitality industry.
Today, Airbnb has become
the fifth largest hotel
chain in the world without
owning a single hotel.
So in the balance sheet,
there's no fixed assets.
Not only that, they can
keep expanding very quickly.
The scaling up is very seamless.
So this is Brian Chesky, the
CEO who says provocatively
that Marriott is planning
to add 30,000 rooms in 2014.
We will do that in two weeks.
So it's a rapid
scale up as well,
which makes it very threatening
for established companies.
So this is on the
sharing economy.
The second movement, of
course, you know very well,
is the maker movement, which
allows everyday citizens
to essentially come up with
their own technical devices
or technology devices.
They make something
in their garage
or in their kitchen
table, and there
was no venue where they
could actually showcase
their MacGyver inventions.
And that's where the Maker
Faire began, as you know,
in San Mateo where I
live on the left side,
and then eventually
is now popping up
in every city around the world.
Every mayor of every city
wants to host this now.
It took place in Rome
two years ago, in Paris,
and I think it's
popping up everywhere.
People call this the
TEDx for tinkerers.
TED is for thinkers, Maker
Faire is for tinkerers.
And to the point where this
is becoming so strategic
is because you begin to see
some of the building blocks
that are powering
this maker revolution,
and this is the open
source hardware movement.
Whether it's the Raspberry Pi
that you know very well, which
is a $30 personal computer
the size of a credit card
invented by Cambridge
University, which
is revolutionizing
computing, and this is today
downloaded over
five million units
have been sold
already, making it
the fastest selling personal
computer in the world.
On the right hand side is a
single board microcontroller,
Arduino, also an
open source hardware,
which allows you
to create devices
that can control and interact
with the physical environment
using sensors and actuators.
Over one million
units sold already.
So these are becoming
essentially the building blocks
of the maker revolution, and to
the point where President Obama
actually even hosted an event
at the White House in June
last year, which was the first
Maker Faire at the White House.
And he said very interestingly
that today's DIY,
do it yourself, is
tomorrow's made in America.
So in other words,
the maker movement
is assuming more
and more strategic
relevance as well
because-- and I apologize,
I'm going to go back to the
previous slide, this one.
Why?
Because now, you begin to have
amazing platforms where people
can go and come up with not
just some small inventions
for personal purpose, but
they could actually start
making companies out of this.
And this is places like
tech shops or fab labs
that are opening up in major
cities around the world,
but people have access
now to cutting edge
industrial tooling equipment
and things like 3D printers.
Of course, in
these pictures, you
might say, well, we see some
people tinkering and coming up
with some interesting solutions
for their personal use,
but you can actually start
disrupting industries
from this platform.
This is what
happened with Square,
which is turning now
every mobile phone
into a mobile payment device.
And this actually was
prototyped and invented
in a tech shop in San
Mateo in the west coast,
and today, it transacts over
$30 billion in payments.
So this is the point, is
that the cost of innovation
is going down.
That means the barriers to
entry are lowering as well.
And this is why, as I
said, President Obama
highlighted this as being
very, very important.
He even has a senior adviser
now in the White House
to advise him how the
maker movement can
become a very important
economic force in coming years.
So interestingly,
I was the adviser
on a documentary film called
"The Maker" that I recommend
you to see, which
actually documents
exactly how this maker
movement is revolutionizing
the society and the economy
in the Western world.
And I have to say,
interestingly, I
assisted in the premiere
of it in the Mountain View
headquarters a
couple of months ago,
and I had the
pleasure to even visit
your maker space in Mountain
View called The Garage.
I don't know if you
have one here in London,
but this would be
interesting to think about as
well, how to create a maker
space as well across Google
campuses to promote the
spirit of making as well.
So what I want to transition
now is to show, actually,
how some entrepreneurs are
using this frugal innovation
mindset to create
solutions that are not just
fun or interesting and sexy, but
actually to solve real problems
in health care, education,
finance, farming, et cetera.
So let me give three examples
that will really fascinate you,
and many of them are
in the books as well.
The first one is in
the health care sector.
It's called CellScope.
They are a Berkeley spin off.
They make an optical
attachment that you
attach to your smartphone,
and it converts it
into an otoscope.
So a mother can insert
it in a daughter's ear
and see if there's
an ear infection.
It just has to send the
video-- it's a short video
image-- to a doctor, and
then within two hours,
the doctor can
send the diagnostic
if it's a problem or no problem,
and if it's a problem, what's
the prescription?
Down the road, they can
also replace this attachment
with another attachment
that can convert
this device into a dermascope
so you can check your skin
condition at home.
This is called the
consumerization
of health care, which is more
and more technology tools using
mobile platforms are being
given to the consumers
so they can take care of health
themselves in a primitive way.
This is the first
revolution you begin to see,
which is essentially what
I call hardware startups.
In Silicon Valley, primarily,
you have software startups,
but you see a plethora of
hardware startups coming up
as well.
So this is in the
health care sector.
If you move on to the farming
sector, this is my neighbor,
and I have a product
with me, actually.
I will check it.
It's called gThrive,
very fascinating.
As a background, California
is the fifth largest producer
of food in the
world, but we have
a huge problem is that
water is becoming scarce.
And very soon,
within two years, we
are going to have a huge
problem in California
with water shortage.
So farmers in California
have a challenge,
which is to do more with less.
So my neighbor has launched
a startup called gThrive.
So these are wireless sensors
designed like a plastic ruler,
and you just essentially
stick in different parts
of your farming
field, and you start
collecting detailed information
on the soil conditions
and ambient environment like
temperature and luminosity,
et cetera.
And it allows,
essentially, farmers
to optimize the use of water,
energy, and labor, while also
increasing their production
and the quality of the crops
as well, the yields.
And the solution pays for
itself within 9 to 11 months.
It's very, very interesting.
You can maybe take a look at it.
So this is what I mean.
It's also interesting because
the first prototypes they built
used Arduino chips.
That means that the
cost of innovation
was quite low at the
beginning for them to get it.
So this is for me the
more exciting kind
of innovation of the
future, these hardware
startups revolutionizing
our health care or farming.
There's one more sector
I want to touch upon
as well, which is directly
core to your sector as well.
This is a French
entrepreneur called
Paul Benoit who has launched
an amazing startup called
Qarnot Computing, which
makes digital radiators.
So they have processors
inside that actually
use the heat generated
by these processors
is harvested to then
heat houses and offices.
So this is an
amazing alternative
to data centers, which we know
are very energy intensive.
And today, data centers consume
2% of the world's energy
consumption, and 50% of the
energy utilization in data
centers is to cool off the
servers because engineers
think that heat is a waste
we have to get rid of.
So this engineer, Paul Benoit,
says no, actually, it's
not a waste.
Waste can be valorized.
We can reuse the waste
to do something else.
So essentially, it's a
distributed computing model,
an alternative to
centralized data centers.
And it turns out.
I was very excited.
Just before I left
my hotel room,
this press release
just came out.
BNP Paribas, which is one of
the world's leading banks,
just teamed up with a
startup to actually take
5% of their risk
management computing
and transfer it
from data centers
to their distributed farm.
So this is also, you can
call it frugal computing,
which is also an
eco friendly way
as well of powering the system.
So now I want to
transition and wrap up
with the most
important part, which
is how can traditional
companies essentially learn
to do more with less, in light
of the fact that consumers
are becoming more
value conscious,
and values conscious as well?
We have these
entrepreneurs trying
to disrupt their
industries as well.
So this is where
the answer to that
is essentially to learn
to innovate differently.
First of all, to innovate
in a more frugal way,
that means with fewer resources.
Secondly, make sure
that they come up
with affordable and
sustainable products
to deliver better value
to consumers as well.
In other words, do more
and better with less,
and that's what we
call frugal innovation.
In a nutshell, frugal
innovation is about-- and many
of you being engineers,
I would be not credible
if I don't have a formula
somewhere in the slides.
So essentially, it's about
maximizing value while trying
to minimize resources.
So it's doing that
simultaneously, if you like.
So the question
is value for whom?
Essentially, value for,
of course, shareholders--
we know that-- but
also for consumers,
and more importantly,
to society at large.
And secondly, it's about
minimizing resources.
Again, what kind of resource
we are talking about?
Well, naturally, financial
resources, but also
natural resources and
time, because time
is the scarcest
and most valuable
resource in our business world.
So essentially,
it's about trying
to do more with less
or better with less.
So in our book, actually,
that you will get a copy here,
we actually have
identified six principles
that companies can implement
to actually change everything
they do in the company, from
R&D to manufacturing, sales,
and marketing in order
to embed this frugality
to the day to day activities.
I will not bore you with the
details of these six principles
that you can learn
from reading the book,
but I want to maybe
synthesize all six
in the form of four best
practices or four key takeaways
that I found that would be
quite interesting for you
to remember.
The first one is about
developing products
that embed four key
qualities or attributes.
The first one is
affordability, as I
said, because consumers
are value conscious,
but it's not about low cost.
Frugal solution is not low cost.
It's about making
something more affordable
but also three other attributes.
Make it simpler to use.
And I always say--
I'm not saying it
because I'm at
Google-- but the idea
is that Marissa Mayer said
very nicely in this quote
in the first book.
The user interface of Google is
that when you enter google.com,
it's very simple,
but behind, you
have billions of
algorithms working.
So the difference
is, as she says,
it's like a Swiss army knife
with all the tools folded
with a Swiss army knife
with all the tools exposed,
which is quite scary.
So this is called
simplexity, which
is you can have simplicity
from a user perspective,
but the complexity happens
in the back office.
So that's a way of thinking
about simplicity as well.
And then sustainability
is important as well,
which is a resource intensive
model is not working anymore,
and then quality.
That's why something
cheap doesn't
mean it's something shoddy.
It has to be good
quality as well.
So I want to give you
some companies who
are trying to integrate the four
dimensions to really disrupt
the sectors.
The first is in the
automobile industry.
This is an example
from Renault-Nissan,
a Japanese car alliance between
Renault, the French car maker,
and Nissan, the
Japanese car maker.
In 2005, they launched
the world's cheapest car,
at least in the Western world,
called the Logan, which I think
may be sold here under
the name of Dacia, which
has now become the entry level
product for the Renault brand.
What is amazing is that
initially, this product
was designed for
emerging markets,
and it gained a lot of
traction in the Western world
as well, especially
in Western Europe.
After the economic recession,
more and more people
now flocked to dealerships
to buy these entry level cars
to the point where the sales
as part of the total sales
revenues of the company
was less than 1% in 2005.
Today, that counts for
over 40% of the company's
total revenues.
It has become the cash
cow for this company,
and Dacia is the fastest
growing brand in Germany,
the country of BMW.
As a matter of fact, Volkswagen
has announced their own plan
to make their own low cost
cars to compete with Renault.
And they're not
stopping here, Renault.
Now they're writing
the next chapter
in the frugal innovation
journey, which is going
to be unveiled in May in India.
This is called CMF-A, which
is a new car platform which
is being developed in India that
will be shared between Renault
and Nissan that will enable
them jointly to produce
a next generation car that will
be even more affordable, even
more comfortable than what they
have had in the past in India.
And initially, they will be
commercialized in the south.
That means India, Africa,
and South America, and down
the road, it might
even be commercialized
in the Western world.
So this is an example of
combining good enough quality,
as I call it, within
affordability and simplicity
as well.
Of course, when I
say frugal product,
I talked about not just
being affordable but also
being sustainable, that is,
using fewer natural resources.
And here, Kingfisher,
headquartered
in the UK, which is Europe's
largest home improvement
retailer, they are
pioneering something
called the circle economy,
which is a movement launched
in the United Kingdom by
Dame Ellen MacArthur, which
is essentially
designing products
in an eco friendly way.
So first, in their case, all the
products over the next 10 years
will use only recycled
materials or materials
that can be easily renewed.
And then, at the end
of the life cycle,
every product can
be disassembled
and the raw materials
can be reused
to make new products
in a continuous loop,
so nothing goes to landfill.
This is called closed loop
innovation, as they call it.
So they want to apply these
principles of eco design
to their 40,000 products
in the portfolio, which
is mind boggling.
So they're not the only one.
About 100 other companies are
joining this circle economy
movement to
fundamentally rethink
how they design,
manufacture, and dispose
of the products over time.
Then, moving onto the
next principle, which
is equally interesting,
is to say, well,
it's nice to have one
or two products that
are frugal and
sustainable, but how
do you fundamentally
rethink your whole supply
chain to make it frugal
so you can reduce
the gap between
supply and demand,
as I said at the very beginning?
The definition of
frugal is that you
reduce the gap in time
and space and resources
between supply and demand.
Well, today, it's not
very easy because look
at the value chain.
You have people making
products far away
from where consumers live in
large quantity, mass produced,
ship them over
miles or kilometers
away from where consumers
live, and then people
drive to supermarkets
to buy them in bulk.
So the whole model essentially
is very energy intensive
and generates a lot of waste.
But imagine a new value chain,
where essentially, supply
meets demand much closer.
Of course, with things like 3D
printers, maybe in 10 years,
we will get to the reality where
we can make our own products,
but meanwhile, we need a
stepping stone to get there.
And this is where, I think,
what Google is doing of course,
with Project Arrow actually
embodies this spirit because
in a way, with
the modular phone,
you essentially push the
production capabilities
down to the consumer.
The last mile becomes the
first mile of the value chain.
It's a fundamental revolution.
So as a result,
this modular phone,
I believe, is going
to revolutionize also
the value chain in
the tech industry,
in a way, because
essentially, you
produce much closer
to your customer,
and it's also more
sustainable because you
can select to replace only
the components that you
want to replace.
So now you might say,
well, this is interesting
because, as you
can see visually,
a cell phone may have about
50 components or less than 100
components, but what about
more complex products,
like a car, which has
14,000 components?
What about drugs, like
process industry, so complex?
How can you make that
much closer to demand?
Well, that's coming as well.
Novartis, one of
the world's leading
pharmaceutical industry, has
teamed up for the past 10 years
with MIT to pilot, and now
they're rolling out in 2017,
a new manufacturing technique
called continuous production.
So continuous production
or continuous manufacturing
is a way of manufacturing
drugs in a micro factory that
is no bigger than this,
and this micro factory
can produce drugs in a
continuous mode 10 times
faster than larger factories
and 50 times cheaper
and can reduce carbon
emissions by 90%.
And literally, it can
fit in a container
and can be shipped
to places if there's
an epidemic or something where
we have to ramp up production
very quickly.
So even in drug
manufacturing industry,
we can start bridging the gap
between supply and demand.
And another example
of, I would say,
the second best
practice is to say,
well, it's nice to
reinvent your supply chain,
but can you reinvent your
entire business model
to make it more frugal?
And here, I think there's
an amazing example, which
comes from the health
care industry, which
is pioneered by a health
insurance company called Aetna.
They are a 160-year-old
health insurance company
and they're completely
disrupting the US health care
system by shifting to what is
known as a value-based care
model.
So if you think about
why that's revolutionary,
because today, doctors and
providers, like hospitals,
are paid on the
number of procedures
they do, like how many
surgeries they perform,
how much medicine
they prescribe you,
but they don't care whether
you're getting healthy or not.
So the health outcomes
is not dependent on them.
The value-based care says
that we will pay providers--
like health insurance
companies will
say-- we will pay you, reimburse
you, only if the patient gets
better.
So they make them more
accountable and also more
cost effective in
how they operate.
So to make that reality,
Aetna is actually
disrupting itself, their
160-year business model,
to become, as they call it,
the Google of health care,
or the Intel insider
strategy, as they
call it, which is
essentially to provide
the kind of technologies
that hospitals
need to make the transition
to value-based care.
And if they make the
transition, McKinsey
estimates that
the US health care
system can save about $1
trillion in the short term
because it's so
wasteful right now,
and this model can create more
accountability and more cost
effectiveness as well.
That's a very
interesting example
that you'll find
also in the book,
where we delve into
more details about how
Aetna is making the shift.
Another very disruptive
business model transition
is Unilever, which is a large
consumer goods company, which
is actually moving to a very
eco friendly business model.
Their chairman and
CEO, Paul Polman,
announced in 2010 the intent
to become the world's cleanest
and most environmentally
sustainable
company by doubling
revenues by 2020
while reducing environmental
impact by 50%, which
is a huge task because they're
going from a 40 billion
euro company to an 80 billion
euro company, at the same time,
reducing their environmental
footprint by 40%, which
is a mind boggling initiative.
They're halfway to that
transition process.
And again, this is a case
study from the book as well.
The fourth one I
want to conclude on,
which is my favorite
best practice,
is imagine the sharing
economy, as I said-- Airbnb
we are sharing apartments.
We are sharing cars--
that's fine, but imagine
what happens if
companies begin to build
collaborative ecosystems where
they can start sharing assets
and resources?
That may sound a
bit science fiction,
but it's starting to happen.
In Scandinavia, this is
an eco-industrial park,
Kalundborg in Denmark,
where about 12 companies are
co-located in a park,
and essentially, they
exchange their
production waste and they
share their resources, like
energy and information as well.
And as a result, they
massively reduced
the use of water, energy,
but also carbon emissions.
And this is called
industrial symbiosis.
That means essentially,
you operate like nature
in a very symbiotic way.
And this is something we
begin to see more and more.
For example, Mars,
the chocolate maker,
they actually share
a distribution truck
with rivals in Germany.
So the idea is that
instead of keeping
the trucks idle for a
couple of hours a day,
why don't we use it to ship
other companies' products?
So this is the idea
of B2B sharing,
which is going to begin to
disrupt a lot of sectors
as well.
But the real exciting
part is once you
begin to share your
employees with others.
What I mean by that is you
begin to get your employees
to collaborate with other
companies' employees.
Why do you do that?
Well, because the
best innovations
come not by keeping
everybody inside the company,
but actually by cross
fertilizing ideas.
So Ford Motor Company has
opened a tech shop in Detroit
where they allow their
own employees, essentially
in their spare time,
to go there and mingle
with employees from
other companies
to get new ideas on how to come
up with disruptive solutions.
And interestingly--
I didn't plan
it-- some of their
upcoming mobile solutions,
with the telematics, are
going to come from this place,
by the way.
Why?
Because they're telling to
their mobile developers,
hey, the software
is fine, but you
need to test it in a real car,
so why don't you come here,
and you can actually prototype
it and test it in a real car
and get very quick feedback.
So you can apply lean
startups in the real world.
So what happened is that two
years after they launched this,
the number of patentable ideas
within Ford went up by 100%
without having to invest
more in R&D, which goes back
to my first slide.
If you want to
innovate more, you
don't have to invest more in
R&D. You need to give more
freedom to employees to tinker.
And this is the model
that's going to be expanded.
BMW, I believe, is opening
their own maker space in Munich.
I believe it's this
month or next month.
So this is exactly the B2B
side of the maker movement,
where essentially, companies
begin to set up their own maker
space.
You'll find more case studies,
examples in our website,
frugalinnovationhub.com,
where there
are gazillions of
video testimonials
and best practices there.
But at this point, I'm happy
to entertain some questions
from you as well.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I know it's lunchtime.
It's always hard to-- I offered
you some food for thought,
hopefully.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: What do you see
as the main driver for this?
Is this the
[INAUDIBLE] recognition
of that current model
[INAUDIBLE] resources,
or is it consumer driven?
NAVI RADJOU: All three,
which is why it's exciting,
because check, check, check.
Of course, to be super blatant,
if it's only for the last two
you said-- save the
planet, who cares?
I mean, it's important, but
for shareholders, it's not.
So this is why it's
disruptive innovation,
because you have to try to
make sure that shareholders
are happy because whatever
you do has a return for them.
At the same time, it
makes you look good and do
the right thing for
the society and planet,
and then it's good
for the consumers,
but you then add a
fourth one, which I think
is very important for you.
It's the employees,
the future employees.
The reason why
Unilever is doing it,
one of the key corporate
officers driving
their sustainability
initiative is their chief HR
officer, human resource
officer, because they say,
well, the only way we can
attract talent in the future
is not by giving
them a bigger salary,
but by having a moral purpose.
That's what I said earlier
in the study as well.
So it's essentially a way of
pleasing shareholders, pleasing
activist investors, pleasing
consumers, and hopefully
attracting talent
as well, which is
why also it's not
that easy to do,
because when you make the
transition in a couple
of years, you have to reinvent
everything in the company,
so that involves a cost.
That involves a financial
cost, involves human cost.
So initially, you may take a
dip in your sales revenues,
so you need to have
strong leadership
to withstand any pressure
you may have from investors,
so that's what
happening with Unilever.
Many of the investors
are criticizing
that the company is caring
more for the environment
than shareholders,
but he thinks,
Paul Polman, that he's doing the
right thing over the long term.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask you
what stops people [INAUDIBLE].
The United States [INAUDIBLE].
NAVI RADJOU: I
think you will begin
to see that some
industries, what happens
is that nobody will do it until
one company begins to do it.
So that's why I gave the
example of this bank, which
is partnering with
Qarnot Computing.
Banking sector is
notorious for it.
The moment one company does
it, everybody else will follow.
So that's why I
always say, I would
rather try to change one
company in an industry
than try to change
the whole industry.
So there's going to be the
peer pressure effect that's
going to kick in very soon.
So I think, adding to your
gentleman's question, that's
the fifth factor, is as
others begin to do it,
I need to get going as well.
So right now, we
did some research.
I would say only 5% of
the largest companies
in the world are
doing it, but that's
enough to begin to create
insecurity in other companies
that say, oh my god, are we
missing out on something?
We need to get doing it as well.
Other thoughts, questions,
comments, reactions,
or anything you want?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: One of
the cited downsides
of doing manufacturing
in China, for example,
is that there is a strong
black market of people
who will copy the process
and [INAUDIBLE] factories
after hours.
If you start moving
manufacturing
closer to the
consumers, is there
a concern that companies will
only use older manufacturing
processes?
They won't do the
innovation where
there are far more people
who can then borrow what
they see as their processes?
NAVI RADJOU: I think with the
open source movement, what
you'll begin to see is that
actually, when you operate--
I'm going to give you a
very specific example that
comes to mind.
There is some initiatives
in France right now around
distributed computing
where actually, they
believe that by
sharing more knowledge
and having a
distributed computing
model for digital manufacturing,
they can accelerate
the innovation in the
manufacturing process
because more people
involved means that you
get more perspective, and
this is the whole open source
movement.
Actually, collectively,
the whole system
gets better and more resilient.
And then there's a second
part of the question,
which is important, is that it
also means that a lot of things
may be open source.
You might say, well, somebody
can grab it and run with it,
and there's a very
nice statement
by the CEO of NanoSatisfi, which
launches nano satellites using
Arduino chips, which is a
mind boggling initiative,
by the way.
And he says, look, we use
open source technology,
and we know that somebody
can take it and run with it
and build their own
thing, but by the time
a large company can
take an idea from us
and actually build a solution,
it will take many years.
By that time, we'll
be light years ahead.
So in other words,
the ethos of startups
is that they are
much faster, and that
means when you're
smaller, you're nimbler.
That's what I'm trying to say.
That also means that by the
time a large company, a Goliath,
tries to steal
something you're doing,
but because of the bureaucracy,
it will take them so long
to actually commercialize
it, you'll already
be multiple versions ahead.
So collectively, it's better
to share than to hoard,
and that's why I say
in the 20th century,
people believed that
knowledge is power.
And today, power is about
sharing and finding knowledge,
and that's why you come
in innocently, by the way.
I'm just transitioning.
People ask me, what is the
role of Google in the maker
movement, things like that?
The more you distribute
things, guess what happens.
There's more friction
in the marketplace.
There is more need for
discovery of services.
As long as centralized--
this is an economic theory.
It's called the
theory of costs, which
is the idea that the reason
you centralize everything
is that you know exactly
what's happening in the system.
You have a corporate directory.
You can find names
and everything.
But the moment
you distribute it,
everything becomes so
distributed that you cannot
easily find potential partners,
so the search becomes super,
super, super vital.
So this is where I
get excited for you
because I think that Google can
play a very interesting role
by leveraging, I would say, its
core, the real essence of what
it is, which is search,
and think about how it can
transpose that in
this model to reduce
the friction in
this frugal economy.
If you do that, then the economy
becomes even more robust.
Other thoughts,
reactions, questions?
I'll give you a free book
if you ask a question.
AUDIENCE: I was interested
in your thoughts
on the environment when you
talked about Google making
a positive impact, especially
on the environment.
A lot of makers, a lot
of production and--
NAVI RADJOU: It consumes
more resources, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NAVI RADJOU: Yeah.
I had the same thought as you.
In 2006, when I started looking
at it, I first was excited.
I'm a technologist, so
I thought, that's great.
And then, yes, I
said, wait a second.
This is actually creating
more waste or something.
And this is the good news.
This is what's going
to happen, next thing.
The first maker movement
was more about, I would say,
having fun, and it was
really about technology
centric movement.
But you might see--
and it's already
happening-- the next wave
is a more sustainable maker
movement, if I can
call it that way.
So the maker movement
is going to go
into two dimensions over time.
The first dimension
is going to become
what they call social making.
That means before making was
an individual act, the tinkerer
alone in their garage.
Now it's going to
become collaborative,
so that's the first dimension.
That's why the tech shops
and things like that.
That's also where I think--
we can talk offline--
but where Google can play a
big role, which is building
the communities around makers.
That's the first dimension.
Second dimension is make
it more sustainable.
So here, what's happening is
that there are companies now
who are beginning to make
the 3D printers themselves
using recycled components.
And then what about
the materials you use?
Well, there's a whole
cottage industry coming up
to say, well, what if you use
recycled materials to make
things?
And then once you
make the stuff,
can you use end of life
cycle these products
you make and bring
it back in the cycle?
So every principle I
talked about in the area
of sustainability, you can
apply that to the maker movement
as well.
But beyond that, there is
a more convincing argument
about the making.
So the 3D printers is
the tip of the iceberg,
but underneath, there's
a science behind it,
and this is called
additive manufacturing.
This is a whole new
way of manufacturing
which the 3D printers
use, which is essentially
by adding layers and
layers, which is much more
sustainable than using the
traditional way of making
things, where you take a
big chunk of wood or plastic
or metal and you
chop off anything
you don't need to
get what you want,
which creates a lot of waste.
Here, with additive
manufacturing,
you don't create that waste.
Nothing is wasted, essentially,
to the raw materials.
So that's why the science
underneath the maker movement,
that is the one that is going
to be a value generating
area for B2B
companies, whether it's
Google or GE or Siemens or IBM.
That's where people
are going to go after.
And in the process, as
scale kicks in as well,
it will also make it more
sustainable over time.
That's a very good
question because I
had the same doubt
for a long time,
but now I'm getting
excited because I
can see how, with
the social aspect
and the environmental awareness,
this could become actually
a much more
sustainable alternative
to traditional
manufacturing over time.
Yes, please.
Judy.
AUDIENCE: I'd love to
hear a little bit more
about the frugal supply chain,
because one example I've seen
out there, but I haven't seen
it anywhere in the UK or even
in the US, but it's
almost a machine
you can go to to get
the book that you want
printed because they
were trying to reduce
the mass printing of
[INAUDIBLE], which I know
is not helping you.
NAVI RADJOU: Yeah.
Actually, it does.
Trust me.
I will explain why in a moment.
AUDIENCE: So can you talk a
little bit more about examples
that you're seeing in
this frugal supply chain?
NAVI RADJOU: So what Judy is
asking is a very profound idea.
Essentially, we are going to go
from just in case manufacturing
model or design principle.
That means what
happens in design
is that-- I don't
think Google does that,
but some of your rivals I know
do that, which is essentially,
just in case design is let's put
all the features in something
just in case there's a use
case that requires the customer
to use that feature,
and then you end up
creating a very bloated system.
As a result, the
supply chain also
gets bloated because
you have to plan
for all these raw
materials you need
to make the product possible.
So the design is where 70%
of the life cycle costs
are determined.
So the more you make the design
cleaner, simpler, whatever
you want to call it, the more
you can have downstream effect.
So I'm starting with the answer
because in the supply chain,
design is the first
stage, in a way.
So I call this just in case
design, which is essentially
that you design just for the
70% needs of the customers,
and then you
incrementally add things.
So that directly comes to, let's
say, a sector like printing,
because one of
the problem I have
is that it sounds interesting.
For example, if I want
to update a case study,
somebody says, hey, there
is a new case study,
well, I have to wait six months
before the next release comes
out.
If I go with the just
in time writing model,
I can create a book
where I only have the six
principles with some
examples, and then I
can make it evolutionary.
And then you might
say, well, that's fine,
but you still have to print it.
So indeed, yes, there's
a big revolution
coming in the printing
industry, and the same thing
like Novartis I talked about.
There's two companies
creating now-- I
don't know if Google
is financing it,
I forgot-- but it's
actually micro printing.
This is going to be
interesting because this
is going to allow bookshops that
are dying to actually become
printing houses.
Why?
Because statistics show
that 60%, for example,
of French people have
memoirs they've already
written sitting in drawers
they haven't printed yet.
Now they can just ship the
file to the local bookshop
and have it printed.
So this is the device that
completely creates high quality
book like this with a
nice cover, everything,
in a small batch.
So yes, this is
where we are heading.
It's micro manufacturing.
And GE, for example, is
moving to the next level
by partnering with a startup
called Local Garages, which
makes do it yourself cars.
Essentially, they
are micro factories
where you can go and
build your own car
using open source design.
And they partner
with Local Garages
to create what they
call First Build.
These are micro factories they
want to open around the world
where consumers can come and
co-create kitchen appliances.
So essentially, that's
something that GE,
known for mass
manufacturing, realizes
that we have to go to the
micro manufacturing model.
This is going to
absolutely revolutionize
publication
industry, appliances,
you name it, even drug industry,
as I said, in the future.
I think initially, the
motivation will be cost,
but I think it's not just that.
I think the bigger factor,
and I haven't mentioned
that explicitly, is a
desire for consumers
to create themselves things
and have personalized items.
This is called IKEA effect.
If you Google, you'll find
some TED Talks on that.
70% of consumers
will keep products
longer if they were involved
in the creation of it.
This is real,
profound values that
is going to accelerate
the development
of micro manufacturing.
Other thoughts, questions?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] any
major companies [INAUDIBLE]?
Or is it [INAUDIBLE]?
NAVI RADJOU: No.
It's actually a good point.
Actually, far from it.
Everybody's rebelling
against it because you
can think about how disruptive
it is for some incumbents.
But it's an interesting way
to answer your questions,
not companies rebelling, but
companies' investors rebelling.
Case in point, Aetna, the health
insurance company, their CEO,
when I interviewed
him, Mark Bertolini, he
was saying that the
investors are not
very happy he's making
the shift because they
are sitting on a lot of
cash, double digit margins.
They keep signing more patients
as customers-- life insurance,
they're selling.
So why change?
So he says, well, very
simple, and I'm rephrasing
what he said from the book.
He says, well,
because if you keep
running on the track we
are running, in five years,
there's no more track left.
We might as well
forfeit the race.
So that means that we have to
proactively begin to shift,
and that's where push back
begins, because whether it's
senior management in the company
or investors, they're like,
why do you want to
change the model that
is working very well?
So that's why it takes a lot
more guts for senior management
to say, well, everything's
going well right now,
but in five years, the drug
industry won't be like this.
So you have to see something
others don't see and then
stick to it, and the
next step is to really
impart that vision to
everybody in the company
so they believe in what you see
as well, and that takes time.
So the rebellion will
happen within, of course,
but also from the
investors as well.
But I think that if customers
are going to ask for it
and you're not going to
attract the right employees
in the future, I think those
are factors strong enough
to get any company to change.
At one point, you have
to realize that investors
are powerful, but
they're not the only ones
that you listen to.
AUDIENCE: Why do you
think that attitudes
about manufacturing [INAUDIBLE]
to decentralize [INAUDIBLE]?
[INAUDIBLE] increase
[INAUDIBLE]?
NAVI RADJOU: So additive
manufacturing initially
will be led by GEs,
Siemens of the world,
building big factories.
And what they're
looking at essentially,
can we take that additive
manufacturing process
and bring it not to make large
scale production big factories,
but embed them in
these micro factories
I talked about earlier.
So that won't happen overnight.
So I agree with you.
It will be a couple of years
before we can transition
to this micro factory model
of predictive manufacturing,
but in the short term,
it's to first create
the proof of concept to
see if it can be done, even
on a large scale.
And then eventually,
it will be brought
to micro factories over time.
But it will be absolutely
led by large companies who
have the wherewithal in terms
of science and technology
development capabilities.
That's why GE is looking into
it, Siemens is looking at it.
I can't name some other
companies, but at least seven
to eight large companies
from the industrial world,
and also from the
IT technology world,
are looking at how
to revolutionize
additive manufacturing.
So my hope is that as
more large companies
jump into it, that will create
more innovation to make it much
more accessible in terms of
bringing it down in scale
so it can be embedded
in a micro factory.
And it won't happen, I would
say, in the next five years,
but over 10, 15
years, it will happen.
Great.
So I think we have
come [INAUDIBLE].
So thank you very much
for your interest,
and you can grab a
book on the way out.
Thanks a lot.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]